ou alors jean-luc lemoine valérie bénaïm
et gilles verdez il y en a deux qui
l'ont vu parmi les trois essais trouver
chez vous ils voient parler tu vas
devoir trouver qui bluffe tout sur trois
l'ont vu il y en a un qui n'a pas vu
qu'il bluffe
gilles verdez hubert c'est vous êtes
antiquaires dans le sud
il aime les jeux il est addict il aime
aussi les garçons et une fille avec une
compagne plus âgés que lui
ça c'est le scénario que vous avez écrit
et qui est extraordinaire parce que
derrière ça y est un film policier
une intrigue psychologique c'est serré
c6 les ja en scylla dans un second rôle
de bout en bout j'ai été pris votre film
est remarquable voilà alors que ce soit
lui qui les murs alors y en a à tous
qu'ils ont vu sur les trois jean luc
lemoine
non mais c'est difficile de parler du
téléfilm sans en révéler trop parce que
vertement à y être entendu c'est patrick
qui l'a écrit et on sent qu'il s'est
fait plaisir déjà au niveau des
dialogues c'est un petit bijou
parce que les et tout est ciselée et il
ya plein de rebondissements ça commence
très fort un peu comme un columbo c'est
à dire des départs il s'accuse et puis
après évidemment on va découvrir plein
de choses parce qu'il ya ce personnage
antiquaires qui est qui est très très
très bien le matin prêté par patrick et
qui va être face à un flic qui coûte 6
un match qui s'appelle nicolas van
beveren a expédié hitano dans le dans le
film et belge a essaimé ses traits sa
vie passe de deux parce qu'il ya
tellement de rebondissements
si on n'en dévoile trop on va gâcher le
plaisir valérie benaïm alors effet
qu'alors vous nous rejoignez il y en a
deux sur trois qui ont vu le téléfilm de
patrick qui passe ce soir sur france 2
lequel bluff lequel ne l'a pas qu
effectivement jean luc a raison c'est un
scénario à tiroirs qui est absolument
machiavélique et avec un fonctionnaire
nous éclairera commandes avec un
face-à-face bluffant entre deux hommes
au centre d'à côté dit l'un que l'autre
sauf que leurs oeuvres pour le bien
l'autre oeuvre par le mal lequel des
deux va gagner jusqu'au bout on ne sait
pas il faut vraiment rester parce que
effectivement à chaque fois des
rebondissements que l'on ne s'attend pas
et le personnage de patrick est vraiment
alors il est presque mutique et en même
temps à chaque fois on se demande ce qui
va marcher
virgin est ton avis kidnappé bulletin
qu'il enlevait lequel bluff le désir
celui ci ont fait beaucoup trop et d'en
tuer leverdez
on vous l'a pas vu patrick à ton avis
qui marche on ne sait pas qu'elle n'a
pas vu dit à ton avis à ton avis c'est
vachement difficile c'est bien mais
c'est à nouveau truc qu'on a trouvé ça
ça on est sur un format sera partenaires
étrangers s'affairent
ça va partir dans le monde entier ça je
connais j'ai le pic pour sa 12 e jean
luc et bien gilles est ce que vous
l'avez vu oui je les ai vus en pardon
gros bisous
[Rires]
jean luc est ce que vous l'avez vu non
de tous les clients que je n'ai pas vu
ses deux meilleurs merci c'est ce soir
avec le tadjik sebastian